this is something you explore
uh quite a bit do you um
yourself
think that there is
a bottom to it where there is reality
there's a base layer of reality
that physics can
explore and our human perception sort of
layer stuff is there's is there let's go
to plato
is there such a thing as truth
i lean towards the platonic view of
things so i believe that mathematical
objects haven't
a reality that
it's not all made up by by human minds
um
and i don't know
where that reality
comes from i can't explain it but but i
do think that mathematical objects are
discovered and not uh invented
um
the um
i i i did a lot of or not a lot but i
did some
some reading of husserole uh when i was
writing anathem
um
and he's a
you know 20th century
phenomenologist and he's writing in the
he's writing at the same time as
as scientists are starting to understand
atoms
and and becoming aware that
that when we look at this table
it's really just a
slab of almost entirely vacuum
and there's a very sparse
arrangement of tiny tiny little
particles there
occupying that space that interact with
each other in such a way that
our brains
perceive this object
so
that's kind of kind of the beginnings of
phenomenology
um
and um and his stuff is pretty hard to
um
hard to read uh it you really have to
take it in small bites um
and go a little bit at a time but he's
trying to come to grips with these
with these kinds of of questions
how did you come to grips with it
like why is this table feel solid
well i mean we're an evolved system that
there's we have biological advantages in
in knowing
where solid objects are so we've got
this system in our head that
that integrates our perceptions into
this
coherent view of things um
the
one of the
take-homes that i i like
from whosoereal is the idea of inter
subjectivity and the idea that
a fundamental
requirement for us to stay sane is
for us to share our perceptions
and have them ratified by other
they don't even have to be people but
um
that you know a a prisoner in solitary
confinement might um domesticate a mouse
or even insects
because
they perceive the same things that the
prisoner perceives um
and uh and so convince
convince him that he's not just
hallucinating yeah there's a
establish a consensus
yeah
but see that doesn't mean it's any of it
is real
you just establish a consensus
it uh it could be very uh yeah
very distant from something that um
something that's real in in um
engineering sense of real
like that you could build it using
physics
but i think that uh you know a valuable
application for an ai robot would be
just
to do nothing except that it just um
so
um consensus it just sits there yeah and
if if you hear a door slam
you might turn to
to see what it is if the robot
at the same time turns
to to look at the door slam it's
ratifying your perception but isn't that
the basis of love
is when the door slams you both look
but for deeper things
you both hear the same music
and others don't i mean isn't that
what that means yeah that's
by love i mean depth of human connection
yeah like
that's
or not you're not here you arrive at
similar
reactions uh without having to
to explicitly communicate it yeah yeah
but we could start with a a robot that
listens explicitly for the slam doors
yeah but no i've or scary sounds i i can
think of so an example of this is you
know
uh
when i when i went to college you know
we'd be sitting at the cafeteria a you
know a bunch of people
you know eating our dinner together that
we had just met let's say yeah
so
a bunch of new people in your life and
um
and someone might make a funny remark or
a not so funny remark or
something would happen
and you might then at that moment make
eye contact with someone you didn't know
at the other end of the table and in
that moment
you would realize
this person is reacting this person
heard what i heard
they're reacting
the way i reacted yeah nobody else
appears to get the joke or to understand
what just happened but random stranger
down there and i we have this connection
yeah and then you build on that so then
the next time
something happens you automatically
look at your new friend and they look
back at you and and before you know it
you know you're
you're hanging out together yeah because
you you know you've already established
without even talking to each other
that uh you're on the same wavelength
yeah it's seemingly so simple
what's so powerful that's establishing
that you're on the same wavelength yeah
at some level yeah
there's no reason why you and a toaster
can't have that
i'm just saying
uh-huh does this smell burned to you
exactly i think it's
if a toaster could just say that to you
yeah
yeah
you